you do it's booked tv's fifth
anniversary fall and this weekend were
in Boston for the Boston Globe Book Fair
betrayal the crisis in the Catholic
Church is based on the Pulitzer
prize-winning reporting of the Boston
Globe spotlight team and you're looking
live inside the old South Boston meeting
house where members of the team will
discuss the scandal and its ongoing
impact on the church this is live
coverage on book TV on c-span too
good afternoon from the Old South
meeting house in Boston and welcome to
today's program of the Boston Globe Book
Festival
our annual celebration of great writing
and great reading my name is David Megan
from the globe staff our series
continues tomorrow at 3 p.m. at the
Charles Hotel in Cambridge as novelist
William Martin reads from his new book
Harvard Yard and next Wednesday night at
6 p.m. at Boston's Fanueil Hall with
Nobel laureate Toni Morrison the center
of today's program is a book entitled
betrayal the crisis in the Catholic
Church by six members of the globe staff
with whom whom I will introduce to you
in a moment it gives me great pleasure
is a usual phrase in introductions such
as these but I suspect that Pleasant is
not the app word for the work these
reporters and authors have done over the
last two years I am sure they would say
that it was satisfying and rewarding but
also appalling revolting and dispiriting
probably not pleasant in the hundreds of
stories which they wrote and in the book
that followed they painfully and
painstakingly documented the sexual
abuse of children by dozens of Catholic
priests in the Archdiocese of Boston
over the last generation and more they
revealed as well the pattern of denial
enabling and cover-up by church
leadership revelations which have led to
the profound changes in the Catholic
Church in the Boston area and in the
United States their reporting and
disclosures resulted in an unprecedented
resignation of a Cardinal Archbishop of
Boston and a turn for them and the globe
the 2003 what surprised
in journalism for public service
speaking as one who knew three of the
abusive priests personally and never
would have suspected them I need not
tell you that the shock of these
disclosures can hardly be overstated the
repercussions of the loss of trust will
be felt for years to come in the church
and in the community generally leading
our presentation today is Walter
Robinson leader of the investigative
group known as the Boston Globe
spotlight team and to my right in order
are several globe writers who
contributed to this project and the book
Sacha Pfeiffer Stephen Kurkjian Tom
Faragher Kevin Cullen and Michael
Paulson there will be time for questions
after their remarks and I would ask
those who have questions to come to the
microphone so that the broadcast
audience can hear you and it will be a
book signing after the program as well I
invite you now pleased to welcome to
listen to the authors of betrayal the
crisis in the Catholic Church Walter
Robinson
thank you very much David for that kind
and warm introduction and our thanks
from the globe to all of you for being
inside this historic place on what may
be one of the last autumn days here in
Boston that can be spent outdoors
without wool socks it may seem odd to
have six journalists all up here
together to discuss just one book in
fact the book has eight authors two of
us Matt Carol and Michael Resendiz could
not be here today for the books
publisher there were so many writers
involved that our names were shuffled
off to the back cover of the hardcover
edition and when the paperback was
published our names disappeared inside
buried at the bottom of the knowledge
mints on page 276 that's page 276 case
anybody's looking but I suppose that's
rough justice the book is after all an
effort not by any one of us or even just
the eight of us but it's an obligation
we all felt at the globe in the midst of
a turbulent moment in the church's
history to pause ever so briefly to put
together the story in the larger context
it deserved before my colleagues give
you a hint of what's in the book let me
briefly set the context the globe's
investigative team set out in mid 2001
to investigate the case of the notorious
priest pedophile John Gagan whose recent
murder in prison is yet another horrific
punctuation mark in the evolution of
this scandal back in 2001 our assignment
was to determine how much the church
knew about his serial molestation of so
many children over so many years what we
quickly discovered was that Gagan was
only one among scores of priests whose
sexual abuse of children had been
covered up for decades by a succession
of boston cardinals and bishops
today almost two years after we began
publishing extensive stories about this
we know that in this archdiocese alone
more than 200 priests have faced
credible allegations of sexual abuse
over 60 years in 2002 the globe
published more than 800 news stories
about the scandal the vast bulk of them
written by the eight of us in early
April in a moment of weakness we allowed
a senior editor to convince us that the
news story was ebbing and that we ought
to write a book and in less than five
weeks we did even as we discovered the
story was not ebbing at all even now
sixteen months after the book was
published it retains all of its
relevancy it contains much of the
history background context nuance and
detail that cannot be easily shoehorned
into any number of news stories for the
next twenty minutes my colleagues who
did most of the writing will tell you
about some of the books highlights and
then we will be happy to take your
questions for the balance of our time
Kevin Cullen we'll start with an
explanation of the church culture that
have helped to make such a long-running
cover-up possible Kevin asked during the
reporting and the writing of the book
and after why this story took so long to
come out and why did it come out when it
came out in the globe actually the the
whole story the issue of clergy sexual
abuse had been kicking around in this
country since the mid 1980s but it was a
story that was always treated as an
isolated incident and the Catholic
hierarchy had its interest in having it
seen that way one case that we dealt
with in the book in our reporting was in
1991 when the case of a former priest
named James Porter who would molested
hundreds of children came to light he
was a priest in the Fall River diocese
that case was dealt with as an isolated
case and
when's the reporting of the globe and
others sought to suggest that it might
be more than that Cardinal law suggested
that it was part of an anti-catholic
agenda and that this was something that
as he said he called the power of God
down on the media and especially the
Boston Globe and most Catholics were
prepared to accept that they did see
that maybe as piling on that there was
maybe too many stories about one case
what changed in the ten years between
the porter case and when the spotlight
team exposed in 2001 the numbers
involved and the showed beyond a
reasonable doubt that this was not
isolated that it was widespread and that
this was covered up is that ordinary
Catholics responded they they were the
ones who were talking about this at Mass
they were the ones who were talking
among themselves and reading the stories
and it wasn't what the globe said it was
the globe it was the records that the
globe obtained it was the church's own
words it was the Cardinals own words and
those are words that held comfort for
the abusers and none for the abused and
that resonated with ordinary Catholics
so that became an internal pressure
which continued on and one of his
stories the episodes we tell in the book
was was in February of 2001 when
Cardinal law convened what you would
call a kitchen cabinet ad hoc advisors
very powerful people in business and
finance and these people included Jack
Connors the founder of the biggest ad
agency in town
Tommy O'Neill the son of Tip O'Neill and
ad man himself
Paula camera the president general
manager of the ABC affiliate in town
these are people who have raised
millions of dollars for the good work of
the church and these were people who
told the condo in no uncertain terms
that they felt like he had not been
straight with them that this that this
scandal was bigger than they ever
imagined that the numbers involved were
bigger than they had been led to believe
and if the Cardinal learned that night
that this was not going to be a support
group it was a group that actually
suggested he needed to resign now that
was an internal pressure it was also an
external pressure the culture of
deference that existed in a place like
Boston where half of the people
in this metropolitan area our Catholic
extended to places of power like the the
legal profession law enforcement
business all those areas these were
people who before were not prepared to
challenge their own bishops and their
own priests over something like this
what changed in in an episode we told
was the case of the Attorney General Tom
Reilly the Attorney General of
Massachusetts grew up in a devoutly
Catholic home until the day he left for
college when he was 18 he was expected
to be home every night to kneel down and
say the Rosary with his family at 7:00
p.m.
fast forward to last 2001 Tom Reilly the
Attorney General of Massachusetts was
prepared and tried to get the his Bishop
indicted for enabling some of these
priests to abuse children that is how
much the culture of deference that
existed in this region had collapsed in
the face of the revelations that came
out in the Boston Globe Minh and then in
other media and that was some of the
episode some of the the cases we tried
to highlight in the book that would show
sort of that this was not just a scandal
involving sexual abuse and a cover-up it
was a cultural phenomenon that attitudes
among people were changing and with that
I'll turn it over thank you Kevin Steve
Kurkjian will now give you some details
about how the archdiocese carried out
this cover-up for so long Steve you're
up the deference that Kevin alluded to
had its greatest effect within the
Massachusetts legislature
it was the masters legislature was not
alone in the showing that deference to
the church in legislatures throughout
the country the diocese and Archdiocese
had been had been excluded from abuse
for reporting allegations of abuse
against children through the 60 70s and
80s when now we know instances of abuse
were great a very few of the cases made
their way to the public
forstman's attention why because very
few of those states required the clergy
of those states Protestant Catholic
Jewish Muslim alike to report
allegations of abuse to authorities in
Massachusetts even though there had been
a statute on the books that had required
professionals in other in other areas
Social Work medicine teachers when they
learned of allegations of abuse they
were required to inform both the DSS
Department of Social Services as well as
the local authorities of an allegation
and if they didn't there could be
criminal penalties against that neglect
that wasn't the case though in
Massachusetts F as far as the clergy was
concerned to avoid bringing dreaded
scandal in church its leaders Cardinals
bishops worked out a scheme the few
times that a parent of a victim would
complain would go to the church and
complain the church would quickly place
the offending priests on sick leave but
soon enough transfer him to another
parish the family of the accused of
excuse me the family of the victim was
assured that the problem had been
severely dealt with and to make up for
the harm suffered to their child a cash
settlement was offered though the
circumstances of the abuse may have been
different case after case one paragraph
in those settlements was always the same
a secrecy agreement that emphasized that
the victim in his family would forsake
the money would have to in fact give it
back if they never made the settlement
known that maintained that allowed the
the the scandal to stay hidden because
very few of these people none of these
families or victims had any idea of the
extent of the abuse in fact the only one
the only only those within the the
archdiocese in Boston knew
the extent of the abuse in 1992 however
that that situation changed a group of
victims of father James Porter from Fall
River step forward to say they had been
abused by the priests and they wanted to
the world to know what had happened
Cardinal Bernard law as Kevin mentioned
expressed outrage over the wide coverage
that that case the papers including the
globe gave to that case and raised
questions about why were we picking on
the church called on the power of the
God our power of God on the media
including the globe to cease to cease
its critical reporting I was one of the
reporters at the globe who was working
on the case at that time and I have to
admit I not hearing from people other
victims I had to think that well I know
the church had had had not lived up to
its responsibilities in this case the
bishops knew what Porter was up to and
hadn't removed him immediately had Allah
had tolerated the abuse but myself
myself thought that this was just a
singular case but it turned out it
wasn't child Cardinal law put into
effect a new policy that seemed that was
highly touted at the time and opened its
eye he opened his arms of the the
church's doors to any victims and but
one point he kept in place just as ever
and that was none of the cases of new
abuse that was reported to the church
none of the people victims who had come
forward at allegations of abuse would be
made known to authorities so for the
next 10 years the scandal stayed hidden
the church spent millions in millions in
secret settlements the church kept their
secret hidden the victims were paid off
believing that it was a singular case
themselves again a singular case and
their lawyers themselves benefited but
the story stayed hidden until the summer
of
of 2000 2001 when the case of John Gagan
B came to our attention thank you very
much Steve next in succession
Tom Faragher and then Sacha Pfeiffer
will talk first times case about the
victims and Sacha about some of the
perpetrators who took advantage of their
positions to abuse so many children
Tom thank you Robbie
stiva gives me a good segue into what I
wanted to speak about one of the one of
the mandates that our editor gave us
when we were tasked with the somewhat
daunting duty of writing the book was
that this not be a recapitulation of the
globe's reporting that we do to the
degree we could in the time we had
original reporting and I was asked to
write about about father Gaghan in part
and just as we were sort of crunching on
the book I needed a sort of a lead
anecdote so I interviewed one of his
victims at a park not far from where
we're sitting today frank leary who was
the lead plaintiff in the civil cases
against against father Gagan and he told
me a story that would be familiar any
any victim of the many people that Gagan
abused and that is of being a ten year
old kid in a church in Forest Hills and
seeing this sort of smiling somewhat
timid somewhat giggly actually priest in
the back of the church who mothers
seemed to love and fathers seemed to
keep their distance from and children
then quite know what to make of him he
told the story of being a rectory
groundskeeper on a hot summer day back
again in the early 70s when father Gagan
bounded down the steps of the rectory
and offered him lemonade and Frank said
no thanks I don't like lemonade and
Gagan insisted and said come on in I
want to show you my stamp collection and
within minutes they were in father
Gaon's bedroom and the in the rectory
and Frank tells the story about him
looking at a stamp collection
didn't interest him at all and father
gagging approaching him from behind and
sitting on having the boys sit on his
lap and then fondling him through his
his gym shorts that day an episode that
was repeated a week or so later I also
wanted to tell you the story about
another victim that among the many that
we interviewed for the for the book and
for the for our reporting very early on
Sasha and I did a story about Father
Joseph Birmingham who was a priest in
suburban Boston here in Lowell and Salem
and other places one of his victims was
a guy by the name of Tom blanch at Tom
Blanchette today is a self-employed
contractor on Martha's Vineyard and four
years after his abuse by father
Birmingham he simmered and found himself
sort of with a hair-trigger temper and
couldn't quite figure out why he was he
was angry and sometime that anger would
boil over he tells the story about
rolling around the New Jersey Turnpike
with a state trooper and thinking my god
what am i doing what's happening to me
anyhow he after 20 years or so he
decides to confront his demons and he
tracks Birmingham down who by then was
living in a rectory in historic
Lexington and he talks about approaching
Birmingham from across the parking lot
as the priest by then quite older than
Blanchett remembers him as a kid was
getting out of his car and he went up
and he said father Burma had remembered
me I'm Tommy Blanchette and he said the
priest was sort of frozen and eventually
invited him into the rectory they had a
conversation and finally Birmingham said
to him why are you here what do you want
from me
and Blanchette said I want to ask you to
forgive me for the hatred I've had for
you over the past 40 years it was a very
powerful story turns out that father
Birmingham shortly after that was dying
and Blanche had kept up his relationship
with him or at least kept in touch
either by mail or occasional visits and
on his last visit he went to the he went
to the rectory in Lexington and the
pastor said no Father Birmingham's not
here he's in the hospital
Blanchette said can I visit him and the
pastor said I can't give you permission
or deny you permission but he did he
went to the hospital
just a little bit north of where we are
right now and Birmingham was in his sick
Betty had morphine IV it oxygen mask on
he was dying in fact he did die that
night with Tom Blanchette holding his
hand and asking God to forgive this man
who he said abused him many many times
as I say father Birmingham died the next
morning Tom Blanchette went to father
Birmingham's funeral which was
officiated by Cardinal law after the
after the funeral Blanchette approached
Cardinal law and said Cardinal you gonna
have some trouble as a result of father
Birmingham's abuse and according to
Blanchette Cardinal law said what do you
mean what are you getting at and
Blanchette said well he abused me and he
abused my brothers and he abused many
many people at the parishes where he
served
according again to Blanche at Cardinal
law at that point said can I pray for
you and Blanchette said short and he
said Cardinal law said some prayers and
then placed his hand over Blanchett's
head and said I now bind you by the
power of the confessional never to speak
of this again
planchette was outraged by that because
he said he didn't come to have Cardinal
law say his confession but just to give
him a warning when Sasha and I reported
that on the front page of The Globe one
Sunday a year and a half ago Blanchette
read it and he read the part where we
had sought a response from the Chancery
and Cardinal law a spokeswoman said he
did not remember that episode the way
Tom Blanchette does but he'd be happy to
meet with Tom if he would want to come
to the Chancery Blanchette being sort of
a very practical man jumped on the ferry
at Martha's Vineyard the next morning on
Monday and drove to the Chancery knocked
on the door and said Cardinal law says
he wants to meet with me I'd like to
meet with him and he was told now you
need an appointment you can't you can't
meet with him the Cardinal secretary
came down and tried to sort of put him
off I guess and at any rate
Cardinal law did not meet with Tom
Blanchett as you said he would until
many many months later when the end was
in sight for for for the Cardinal and
that was the when Tom Blanche I finally
got to confront Cardinal law about that
episode the term thank you very much and
if I hadn't leaped to the podium if we'd
gone on about this Tom Tom would have
told you that when all the documents
came out there was extraordinarily an
extensive documentation that the
archdiocese had known for years going
back to the early 60s about father
Birmingham's abuse Sacha Pfeiffer will
now talk about some of the perpetrators
thank you first I want to say I speak
too quickly
and knowing that I only have about four
minutes I'll probably speak even more
quickly so I'll try to go slowly but if
I start to cruise please flag me down
one of the things we talked about a lot
when we were doing our reporting was how
we present this abuse in a way that
would never be accused that we couldn't
be accused of being salacious or of
sensationalizing what we were writing
about because in many case we write it
about obviously sexual encounters and we
developed this sort of expression among
ourselves that molest is not a six
letter word and what we meant by that
was we wanted not to have people think
of this word molest and forget the
details of what that meant because in
every case it was different it was very
skillful it was very manipulative these
were carefully cultivated relationships
that began often with emotional bonds
and eventually became physical for many
of these kids it was the first time
they'd ever had any experience with sex
I wrote a story once about a boy who had
had a sexual relationship with a priest
for several years the day that story ran
I got a very angry call from a man who
said if that relationship went on for
several years it absolutely was
consensual and then he offered this
example he said when he was younger he
had been skinny-dipping in a quarry on
the south shore at one point he was
alone at this quarry and the stranger
came up and grabbed him and he said when
that happened to me I knew to run away
as fast as I could but you know the guy
was missing the point which is that
these weren't strangers grabbing you in
a strange place
these were relationships that were taken
very slowly and very carefully so in our
newspaper story
we were very limited by both time and
space and how much detail we could offer
one of the nice things about the book is
that we could actually write about some
of these priests in some of the cases of
abuse in detail there's a chapter called
predators in which we profile about five
of the worst offenders in the Boston
archdiocese and then one nationally
Robert troop II in Arizona we wrote
about Gagan which people know best
probably we wrote about joe birmingham
who was very Gagan like in profile he
was at six parishes in about 30 years
complaints came in from the very
beginning there are at least 50 victims
there's he has one of the most organized
victim groups it's called survivors of
joseph birmingham he died in the late
80s we wrote about Ron Pak when a priest
to again complaints came in from the
very beginning Paquin actually caused
the death of a boy he was driving back
from New Hampshire after a weekend away
car flipped on a freeway a boy named
Jimmy Francis died Paquin is now in jail
Paul Shanley who people probably know is
one of the most notorious because he
created for himself a ministry and he
worked exclusively with troubled
teenagers often kids struggling with her
sexual identity he's now awaiting trial
we read about Bernie Lane who ran a
treatment center for troubled teens in
Littleton Massachusetts so that gave us
an opportunity again to give some detail
but one thing I'd like to get across
today is the volume of priests who did
this in between about January 2002 when
we wrote our first Gagan stories in
April 2002 when we were it published in
our book something like 90 priests names
were turned over to Massachusetts law
enforcement officials 170 priests across
the country resigned or were placed on
leave to date I think the Boston
archdiocese has turned over between 150
and 200 files so that included
accusation these are some going back
years the file canvas were spilling out
with this I mean this argument that it
was a few bad apples is just not true
once in a while people call to us call
us and they say why was there such a
problem in Boston or why was there such
a problem in New England and that's
frustrating for me to hear because this
is not a local or regional problem we
just happen to get the file cabinets
open by going to court and finding a
judge who who agreed to lift a
confidentiality seal so that's I think a
message I hope people will be left with
today that's it thank you Sasha
Michael Paulson
the globe's extraordinary religion
reporter has had somewhat of a unique
view compared to those of us who wrote
almost exclusively about the misdeeds of
the priest Michael covers the church in
the Cardinal and the Chancery and has
been very close to the story all along
of how this has affected the church
Michael who's we thank you for being
here today he's just back from Rome
where he has been writing about the
Vatican and our Pope and thank you for
being here Mike thank you I guess I'll
start by reminding you all what you must
know which is that this story these
hundreds of stories that we all wrote
over the last couple years have had a
more dramatic impact on this institution
this church than any story I think any
of us have ever been involved with it
had an impact on policy on personnel and
on perception of the church on the
policy front both locally and nationally
the church has made quite dramatic
changes in the way it responds to
allegations of abuse on a personnel
front you all know it led ultimately to
the resignation of the Archbishop of
Boston an unprecedented step and
numerous bishops around the country
stepped down because of their own
personal misconduct and it led to the
removal of more than 400 priests around
the country who had been accused of
abuse and various diocese and of course
on the perception front the crisis has
dramatically changed the way laypeople
and priests and even bishops see the
church in this country and around the
world my job is to talk a little about
the issues that I cover the future of
the church which is the largest
Christian denomination in the world
claims a billion adherents
this is not something I can easily do in
four minutes so I'm just going to
mention a few issues and then if you
want to talk further about them during a
question and answer session we can on
the local front the the first and most
significant issue facing the church is
preventing a recurrence of the crisis
that we've been writing about the
Archdiocese of Boston has put into place
new rules for screening priests for
training workers and has pledged to
remove from minus--
any priest who is credibly accused of
abuse the archdiocese has agreed to
settle litigation brought by more than
500 people who were affected by the
abuse crisis with a price tag of 85
million dollars that's going to worsen
an already existing financial crisis for
the archdiocese we expect that it will
lead to sales of property to parish
closings to a continuation of some of
the school closings that we've seen over
the last couple years a priority for the
archdiocese and for the new archbishop
is obviously going to be healing for
victims there are hundreds of people as
I say who are affected by abuse by
priests in this area the archdiocese has
promised to pay for ongoing therapy for
them and the archdiocese has to work on
healing for laypeople and priests many
of whom have had their confidence in
this institution severely shaken over
the last several years on the national
level the church has been affected
everywhere the church for the first time
passed a National Child Protection
policy this past year the US Conference
of Bishops had been talking about the
problem of sexual abuse since 1993 but
it wasn't until these stories were
published that they finally set about
passing a national policy that
ultimately requires every diocese to
remove priests who are abusive but
perhaps more importantly the National
Church is taking several steps that
could dramatically change the way we
understand what took place over the last
several decades they've commissioned two
studies one of which is about the scope
of abuse in this country which is
scheduled to be released early next year
and the president of the US Conference
of Catholic Bishops has said that he
expects the results to be startling in
terms of the numbers that it will reveal
they've also agreed to release a study
about what they see is the causes of
this crisis which as you all can imagine
is a very hotly contested issue and at
the Vatican's insistence they've agreed
to an inspection by the Vatican of all
American seminaries these are the
institutions were priests are trained
finally on the global front this crisis
opened a Pandora's box of issues that
have been confronting the Catholic
Church in the US and in the West
at least since the 1960s that are now
being discussed much more openly by
people at all levels of the church those
issues include celibacy what is the role
of requiring most priests to be celibate
not technically open for discussion in
the church but it's being discussed
increasingly nonetheless there's a new
Cardinal who was created last week from
Scotland who has said that he believes
that the church ought to be discussing
whether priests should be allowed to get
married the role of women in the church
the role of authority we've seen locally
a new lay organization form voice of the
faithful and a new priests organization
the Boston priests forum which are
testing whether or not there is a
greater role for lay people in priests
and the decision-making power of the
church the issue of homosexuality which
is hotly contested in terms of whether
or not the number of gay men and the
priesthood played a role in the scope of
this crisis as Robbie mentioned I'm just
back from Rome I was there for the last
two weeks covering the Pope's 25th
anniversary of his papacy as well as the
beatification of Mother Teresa and as
you can imagine with the Pope being so
sick there's quite a bit of discussion
in and around the Vatican about an
upcoming transition at the Vatican about
who the candidates are likely to be for
the next pope and what kind of changes
that will entail and one thing that
we'll be watching is whether as there is
transition at the Vatican as well as in
the Archdiocese of Boston
whether we'll see an increasing emphasis
on a return to orthodoxy as is being
called for by the conservative forces in
the church or whether there's a push for
greater reform as is being pushed
forward by progressive forces in the
church those the issues I'll be watching
and coming months and years and with
that I think I'll stop and take
questions thank you thank you very much
Michael
Kevin Tom Steve and Sasha this is this
is an issue in which we think we've just
sort of touched on of just a few of the
issues and it's one that whenever we
talk about it people want to engage and
ask questions and
throw brickbats our way so please if you
if you can ask a question and please use
the microphone yes ma'am
Oh
you said you look for a judge I should
that was poor wording oh we we
coincidentally got a certain judge who
felt that it was in the public interest
to have that case an unfiled I'm sorry
unsealed the hysteria was that the case
against John Gagan had been sealed by
the court at the request of the church
the church had argued it was private a
judge agreed and sealed the case when we
went to look in in the spring of 2002
Cardinal law had admitted in a routine
legal filing that he knew before he sent
gag into his final assignment at st.
Louie and Weston he was aware that he
had allegedly method molested seven boys
that was big news because that changed
the story from one about priests to
abused children to one about church
leaders who covered up for priests who
abused children the globe had a new
editor of the time Marty Baron we we a
columnist had written about this case
file being sealed Marty Baron said why
is this yeild shouldn't we challenge it
the globe lawyers went to court it took
many months and we began our research
beforehand but ultimately a judge agreed
that it was in the public in public
interest to have that case file open
we didn't judge shop know ok but what
about I'm wondering about the process of
crafting the request to the court did
you find a lot of false leads was it
pretty clear from the beginning how to
state it or a the the fact that you were
able to get a judge to force the
archdiocese to give up those documents
is really the crucial step and I've been
wondering a lot about all aspects of
that thank you well let me address that
we have an extraordinarily good First
Amendment lawyer Jonathan albino and
once he was asked to look into this he
forged an argument that notwithstanding
whatever rights the church thought it
had to keep this information about its
personnel records secret that there was
given the issues involved and overriding
public
interest in in having access to those
records and since our agencies of
government including our courts normally
operate publicly the judge after
considering that considering this
decided that in fact the record should
be released and the same judge was then
after the story broke given stewardship
of all the claims and using the same
legal justification which has been
upheld ruled that the personnel records
of all the other priests had to go to
the lawyers and be filed publicly in
court and made available which is why so
much more is known about what happened
in Boston than in any other venue of the
country I want to add about the judge
talking about the culture of deference
collapsing or at least eroding judge
constant Sweeney who made these rulings
was a product of Catholic education she
went to Catholic Grammar School she went
to Catholic High School she went to a
Catholic college but she ruled that
obviously that this was in the public
interest so it was just another example
of that just the power structure that
the courts everybody in legal circles
have been part of keeping the cover-up
going because it kept everything secret
she was the one that actually unsealed
the records and I want to know quickly
that we wrote a story about the many
judges who over the years sealed various
abuse case cases and one of those judges
we were able to interview when she
acknowledged that she believes she
probably did that in error now when she
realizes the extent of the problem yes
question please presuming the extent of
the prevalence of the sexual abuse was
extraordinary
and the nature of the Catholic Church
had hasn't changed in its secrecy and
self protectiveness and alluding to the
issues mr. paulsen brought up some
people blame attic and to some people
blame the sexual permission of society
some people blame celibacy did your
personal investigations give you any
insight into your own beliefs about why
what happened
I mean why it's suddenly was so
prevalent and
the sexual abuse I mean with sunway
super maybe maybe six different opinions
on this issue and in within the room
fifty different opinions Michael why
don't you go first on this this is
obviously an issue I mean this is a very
difficult question and as I say the the
bishops conference itself is starting to
grapple this question of what caused
this crisis and whether in fact the
problem in the Catholic Church was worse
than in other institutions we did try
and take a look to compare the
prevalence of abuse within Catholicism
to other religious denominations and we
couldn't find anything comparable in any
other denomination I think you have to
say there are multiple factors that
contributed to what took place here
clearly there was inadequate screening
of candidates for the priesthood in the
particularly in the 50s and 60s there
was an inadequate response to complaints
about abuse from parents and even from
other priests and sometimes nuns the
archdiocese would hear that a priest was
of concern and would not act to remove
that priest from jobs in which he had
access to children so priests were
allowed to continue to violate children
but then there are these issues of
secrecy some people argue that there was
a culture in which Catholics were
encouraged not to take on the church not
to bring scandal on the church not to
question the actions of a priest or the
decisions of a bishop Church was very
interested in preventing scandal in
preventing anything that might damage
its image in the broader society
obviously a strategy that ultimately
backfired quite badly and you know the
role of issues like celibacy and
sexuality and gender are very hotly
debated people tend to come at those
issues with their own preconceived
ideologies and you find that both from
the left and right people read into the
crisis the the problems that they
already saw before the crisis began
somebody else want to jump in here
I think I just say generally that why it
happened I think is the most complicated
issue of it all and probably
unanswerable in many ways as one one
among us among several of us who was
raised Catholic and my case went to 12
years of Catholic school I've reflected
a lot on the issue of celibacy and there
are a lot of priests who would disagree
with me on this but I I think of a
church that recruits people and
essentially says to them if you want to
be a priest you cannot have emotional or
deep emotional attachments you have to
live alone you cannot marry it it really
narrows really narrows the pool from
which the church is drawing its priests
and in a way which I believe contributed
to this as Michael said the incidence of
this we we can find no match for it in
other congregations and speaking roughly
of the numbers over the period of time
which we studied about 50 years roughly
five to seven percent of the priests in
the Boston archdiocese were accused of
in that period of sexually abusing
minors yes ma'am please hello my name is
Patricia and I'm from the Malden Medford
Summerville area that covers it all
raised by sisters of st. Joseph and my
three children who are all grown out
they were raised by nuns and priests in
Malden I have a question has been
pondering me since the very beginning
time when this first started coming out
in the newspapers both my boys were
altar boys growing up kawaiiboys very
involved in the church we all were quiet
cetera so in this can I asked one of my
grown sons happens to be in law
enforcement now do what we call any of
the priests
you know father so-and-so and so on ever
doing anything in pretty
appropriate or that your question doe
that you would have come home and told
you said well one time father so-and-so
whacked me over the head and I said he
did what did he do that for he says well
I dropped the chalice in the sacristy so
probably that was justifiable cause for
whacking when they had I think what I'm
questioning is going back to a number of
years where you people talk about today
that parents went to either their past
or some end remember the clergy reported
allegations of stories that their
children came home with they in turn sat
down with whoever whatever member the
clergy and told their story
however real it was to them how it
realized the children and then accepted
money on the basis that they would never
reveal their allegations their knowledge
of the stories their children had told
them what I question is while that is on
a moral issue this is also a crime and I
wanted to know if any of the board
members have confronted any of these
parents they took the money and what did
they do with the money was any of the
parents ever questioned about the money
that they took in lieu of their
children's mental and physical welfare
granted they may have signed documents I
can only tell in my own case and growing
up of my own children I know full well
my husband and I would never have gone
that route this is a crime we would have
very clearly sought law enforcement as
an answer to that and as you've said
here perhaps some of these parents I
don't know if the word is accountable
but to take thousands and thousands of
dollars and a lot of these people that
were that were allegedly or they were
abused they have still grown into be
trouble adults and they in turn perhaps
will abuse other people so my question
is I wonder if anything was pursued
along that line as far as the monetary
and financial rewards are payoffs that
they receive
in light of their children's welfare as
I said I know from my own background
raised in a parochial and my husband the
way we felt when I children came home we
would have sought out law enforcement
first thank you what we found for the
dozens of victims who had called and
stepped forward and to talk to us is
invariably they did not come from stable
homes invariably the children who were
abused came from broken homes or came
from homes with the parents were not did
not have we're not the children are in
stable family environments as a result
they had no place in order to sit at the
table or a mother or father who would
draw them out and would believe them and
those kids it was almost like those were
the kids that the priests the clergy
knew needed some stability or some
comfort and those are the kids that the
priests would focus their attention a
majority out of them were more than the
majority mother but sorry Steve go ahead
yeah bulk of them so so that that's one
for one reason one reason that you
didn't have family saying what's going
on here this is a this is a crying to my
child I'm going to the authorities you
they invariably the parents also were
told that this is the parent or the
child to who may have grown up by now
and was bringing the complaint to the
church was told that this was a singular
event this was just one time and that he
or she of the parent would be doing harm
to a wonderful institution which it is
you know one thing that this this
institution does is provide
extraordinary support to the to the poor
and to the homeless the in our society
and that that that speaking up would
bring scandal upon the church and what
in the end hurt the church so invariably
the fan parents did not seek to make it
public when one thing that
we ought to make clear and the book the
book does is that from our experience
the vast majority of the children who
were abused did not tell their parents
at the time they didn't tell their
siblings they were afraid too and in
fact once this scandal broke open we
received calls from more than 300
victims and in many of those cases they
had kept this inside them for years and
had lived with us and were telling for
the first time their story to reporters
and so by the time they came forward
whether it was in the 90s or prior most
often the criminal statute of
limitations had long since run out and
the only remedy was this civil action I
think I'm referring to a long time ago
where millions of dollars were paid out
to various guardians or parents or
whatever you know I would people please
correct me if I'm wrong I don't think we
saw that many payments till to the late
80s and early 90s and the payments
typically went to families they were to
now adult men who were reporting abuse
that happened when they were younger so
I think that's sort of a misperception
that there were family families and moms
dads yes take away big mom sometimes and
also I mean we have talked a lot of
parents who to this day beat themselves
up for not having done more another hand
some did everything they could think of
they went as far up the food chain in
the churches they can they had meetings
of the Chancery they were assured it
would be taken care of the priests
disappeared years later they learned the
priests went from the South Shore to the
North Shore and we have at least we had
at least one or two police records
I think someone in Hull a police officer
in Hull found a priest parked with a kid
priest pants down midnight in a parking
lot and you know he sent the priest home
he went to the bishop the next day and
said you have a problem take care of it
so I think people encountered police he
didn't want to get involved it's fear
and it becomes a conspiracy of silence I
think so thank you very much thank you
yes sir hi my name is Velma okay and
first of all thank you for the work
you've done I started off not being
encouraged by what I was reading and as
it went on more and more found a need to
to concentrate on it so I'm grateful to
you for bringing my attention to
the question I have is that I can
understand that the need to avoid a
scandal in any large institution is
probably reasonable with a extent
provided there is an internal
methodology of handling it or some
balance within that institution could
you tell me if you found anything in
your investigations or what you found in
your investigations that show what was
going on inside the church
what pressures were there that were
seeing this and working towards a
solution towards that or was there
anything at all to a minimal session
well typically what would happen was in
reading the tens of thousands of pages
that we now have at our disposal is
there would be a an accusation a
complaint the priest would be
immediately brought to the Chancery by
the Cardinals delegate the person
designated to investigate and there
would be there would be meeting there
would be a meeting there be notes taken
and very often the priests would be sent
to for examination and one of the
treatment centers either in outside of
Washington or there was one in Canada
and one in Hartford
but until very recently the the priest
would as I say be evaluated and the
church sometimes would argue for the
evaluation it it wanted which was that
this priest was fit to be returned to
service and very many times that's what
that's what happens so they did have a
mechanism and in the early 90s they they
formalized the policy but they just
didn't it was it was a toothless policy
and it did not it did not they obtained
the protections that the architect of
that policy whose Bishop mcCormick in
New Hampshire now had hoped thank you
yes man please
I want to respond I want to respond to
this woman who was up before me when are
we going to learn to stop blaming the
victims when she said something about
the parents responsibility God you know
what I heard Cardinal law that was his
thing
the parents didn't do this the parents
didn't do that are we ever as a society
going to stop blaming the victims and
get you the real culprits here thank you
thank you very much anybody want to
comment on that yes sir good afternoon
first of all congratulations to all of
you fund the Pulitzer Prize enormous ly
well deserved and really gutsy it occurs
to me that the people who wrote who
built this place a saying to themselves
we told you so
but the talk has been about how could it
happen in Boston how did they happen in
Boston Boston Globe today 50 cents pigby
one
it's about benefits the same-sex
partners I'm going to read one paragraph
and I will riff on it a top deputy of
House Speaker Thomas Finneran said
yesterday he sees a window of
opportunity to greatly expand benefits
for same-sex couples in the next year I
hope you're sitting for this now that
the state's Catholic Bishops have
signaled a willingness to discuss
granting benefits to domestic partners
whatever happens inside the church
whatever the causes inside the church
are internal but when you have that
written about something going on up at
the Statehouse four blocks away there's
the other side of this this undue
deference that hasn't gone away yet and
I'd like to hear your comments on that I
was raised as a Catholic by the way
thank you that's a fascinating issue I
actually take that and other things that
have happened since this scandal
exploded into public view as as evidence
that the church's clout its credibility
in the public arena has been seriously
eroded and I ask my colleagues whether
they
leave two years ago the church would
have the bishops would have in effect
come halfway and said no we're against
same-sex unions but we'll consider
supporting benefits for domestic
partners Kevin well I mean the other
thing I think I used the word collapse
in terms of the culture of deference I
think a better word is erosion and the
reality we have to get back to the
reality is that this is the only
metropolitan area in the United States
where over half half of the population
is Catholic the legislature I think I
think is still about 70 percent Catholic
which is so the influence is not going
to drop overnight but the reality is I
mean I just look at my my own upbringing
I mean on Fridays during Lent no one ate
meat you know you didn't you didn't miss
mass or if you miss mass you went to
confession all these things that
Catholics live by it isn't like that
anymore and so it's the same way when it
comes to politicians are they voting the
way the bishops tell them to vote I
don't see any evidence of that to the
extent that maybe a generation ago but
this is an evolutionary process and so
it's not like because of the scandal all
of it all of a sudden people who were
raised Catholic are not culturally
Catholic and that is why the bishops
still retain whatever the bishops say
we're going to generally if it's a big
moral issue a big societal issue its
front-page news
and so we shouldn't I don't think we
should overstate as Robbie said I think
their influence has diminished but it
still is a giant influence because it's
you know every week people are still
going to church and listening to what
their bishops say thank you Kevin sir we
have time for one more question and it's
yours the many discussions I have had on
this issue I've tried to find a
proverbial silver lining I'm basically a
half-full person and the best i've come
up with is something like these things
aren't happening anymore if they do
happen they'll be very quickly dealt
with if they were cover-ups that we
quickly exposed and we should be
grateful for that people I have talked
to haven't always been convinced I was
wondering how much validity you think
there is to my reasoning on that Michael
I guess if you want to look for a silver
lining you have led me directly into a
quote I brought from the Pope in his
initial response to this crisis and this
is what he said last April when he
brought all the Cardinals of the United
States over to talk to him about this he
said we must be confident that this time
of trial will bring a purification of
the entire Catholic community a
purification that is urgently needed if
the church is to preach more effectively
I think many Catholic officials have
said that they believe that this crisis
is going to improve the church because
there obviously was a problem children
were being harmed and the hope is that
as a result of this crisis fewer
children will be hurt thank you Michael
thank you sir for that concluding
question and on behalf of all of us at
the globe thank you all very much for
being with us today
for anyone who's interested we do have
betrayal the crisis in the Catholic
Church is available in paperback from
back pay books an imprint of little
brown and company to learn more visit TW
bookmark com